[Music]
are those human remains you guys have a
permit for that shut up Phillip FFF you
don't talk to me like that you want me
to be Tess I'm just out of here Phillip
I will eat your sweater vest for dinner
always been a
douche listen monk you need some time
off why don't you go back and spend a
little more time with your family you
know that all successful Riders are
tormented by their families you look fat
okay
never welcome home baby how the I
don't feel like much of the wrem lately
your books change people's lives
something I've written hav changed your
life absolutely my dining room table was
wobbly as hell before your last book
came out it was like
perfect how's your brother doing I still
live in Tucson what's wrong with Tucson
there's one gay bar and it's full of
college kids one of them asked me if I
was Tyler Perry I mean Tyler Perry lives
in Atlanta
right and news editors they want a black
book they have one I'm black and it's my
book look at what they expect us to
write would you read an excerpt yo Shir
where you be going in a hurry like that
if and you got to know I was going to
the
pharmacy oh when you
[Music]
live if they want stereotypes I'll give
them
one what is this dead be dads rappers
crack and black right nobody's going to
publish this just want to rub their
knows isn't it we love it what what it
is very uh black yes that's it I'm happy
you said it and not
me I wrote it that's a joke people want
to love you Monk you should let them
love all of
it we sold the movie right yes we think
it is going to be the bestseller I'm
sure white people on the Hampton will
Delight in it yeah we will they they
it's going to be
huge can you stick around and help with
mother I got to get home it's 8:00 in
the morning I'm not flying the plane
[Applause]
manom